[Music]
a Royal Marine Brant band welcome Prince
Harry and his fiancee Megan Marple to
Scotland this morning for their first
official visit there
the couple is visiting a cafe called
social bite that helps support the
homeless celebrities such as George
Clooney and Leonardo DiCaprio have been
known to visit the sandwich shop as well
Charlie d'Agata is at Edinburgh Castle
Charlie good morning good morning well
the excitement had been building up all
morning as the couple's pre-nuptial tour
brings them here to Scotland where
Prince William and Kate first fell in
love now we had a chance to visit that
cafe to find out what makes it such a
magnet to mega stars on both sides of
the Atlantic a biting north wind did
little to chill the enthusiasm of Scots
welcoming the prince and his bride-to-be
to Edinburgh the iconic Edinburgh Castle
provided the stage to the couple's first
official joint visit to Scotland their
next stop considerably less grand a
pretty unremarkable cafe that has done
some pretty remarkable things for the
homeless social bite and Megan Markel is
not the most famous Hollywood star to
visit George Clooney's a fan and
Leonardo DiCaprio and though founder
Josh little John had courted Hollywood
royalty the requests from well actual
royalty came as a surprise just got an
email was saying and Prince Harry Megan
microcline to visit Edinburgh on this
particular date and they would like to
come and visit social bait cat thinking
yeah I think I can make that happen
yeah thinking you know wow his
restaurants not only feed the homeless
but employs them too and all profits go
toward helping their plight catering
assistant Sonny Marie used to be a
heroin addict mother just speeds pumping
the Burton get any trouble and getting
Pleasant things like that so so sort of
a taking a challenge there having a job
that's taught with
Malloy the ability to change lives is
one reason convincing george clooney to
sprinkle a little stardust to raise the
charity's profile isn't hard George
Clooney was just unbelievably charming
and funny and he had to hold staff in
stitches and I've never you know
experienced anything quite like that
with all this women that were hewn from
6:00 in the morning and while that
spotlight helped Prince Harry and Megan
Markel take notice
battling homelessness is an issue the
couple have already held close to their
hearts the couple also planned to attend
a ceremony marking the achievements of
young people as for tomorrow Valentine's
Day Megan Marco said in the past hook
line and sinker she's a sucker for
Valentine's Day we don't know their
plans what we do know is they've taken
the day off work with no official
engagements planned Johnno but probably
is a great Valentine's Day just nothing
on the schedule for them that's night so
I like that they're already planning and
that maybe they'll do something special
I like what he said George Clooney is
unbelievably charming he is absolutely
true Charlie d'Agata and Scotland thanks